[Music]
on today's show we talked to a return
caller who's calling back to let us know
how things are going and some new
challenges she's experiencing with her
kids we also talked to a newlywed who's
already dreading the holidays and the
conversation with her mother-in-law oh
boy stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john deloney's show we're so
glad you're with us
[Music]
we're talking about relationships and
mental health and
love and
i don't know
tenderness and hope what are some more
happy words flowers
and bumblebees and punctuality i'm late
this morning i'm late
and james decided to mention that to
america so congratulations james you win
i just said a word
just one word
man you must be so fun to be married to
just
dinner is how you do it it's dinner
children
is this one of those times where you
turn the conversation on someone else
yeah cause i have low self-esteem i'm
sorry
it's cool man
sarah good to see you james our show is
today
or not really
i mean our uh our sound checks today
me and james are in a band and we're
incredible and we're gonna win it all
and
just saying hey i think this would be
awesome you could point out to america
what kind of guitar are you playing in
this show
i still haven't decided
whatever
the photos of you just smoking that sg
are gonna be so great
um
and for those of you who think that was
a drug reference it's an awesome gibson
guitar all right let's go to michelle in
pensacola florida good morning michelle
what's going on
i'm doing great how are you we are just
saving the world
what's up
um so i i was a previous caller um about
my daughter you had given me some advice
in the past we were awaiting a diagnosis
yes
hey so first let me say this
did i screw it up the first time
no you did not screw it up okay good i
was hoping you weren't calling me to
tell me i was an idiot and
um so you were one of the first callers
one of the og's way back in the day
yes i was on one of your first shows i
was so excited about that
and it's just continued to go
since then but hey thanks for hanging
with us
uh okay so you called and you had
let give us a reminder of what was going
on
so my daughter she was two at the time
and there were some delays going on and
i called asking for some advice because
you know i was worried that
i
wasn't doing enough for her to make sure
that she was where she needed to be
kind of just you know in an uncertain
spot so you helped me through that and
you know found my community where we
were uh but we have some fun relocated
because we are a military family
and we also have gotten an official
diagnosis for cadence as well okay so
what's the diagnosis
so she actually has a it's a somewhat
rare genetic condition
and
it causes epilepsy which we got the
official diagnosis for that
uh back in april so we she's having
silent seizures and it also along with
that
are
there's an intellectual delay there's
she still doesn't talk she's almost four
she'll be four in november
and she's got a movement disorder as
well so she is always a clumsy child
so
with the
um is the epilepsy disorder is that
really the
are the doctors saying that's the root
and these other things are derivative
um so it's actually the epilepsy is
derivative of the
genetic condition that we just got the
diagnosis of the genetic condition uh
last month okay all right and you've got
a little one too
yes so uh eden is nine months old now um
because why because why not right why
not relocate in the middle of a pandemic
plus get your special needs diagnostics
for your little one and then have a
nine-month-old
yeah just go all in
wow okay so
tell me how that's going
it's going great cadence is an amazing
big sister it's so hard with her not
being you know not being able to
communicate but
she
she loves eden she comes over she gives
eating kisses all the time when i'm
feeding her
she plays with her like she's she's
doing so well and there were so many
uh you know worries that i had in my
mind because people kept telling me how
terrible cadence was going to take it
but they were wrong
yes and so you just told me something
important i know we haven't even got to
your question yet
there's a difference between
non-communicative and non-verbal and so
your daughter
may not be speaking yet but she's truly
communicating a lot is that fair
it is yeah it's definitely fair it just
looks much different than what i
expected
all right so what's your question
yeah so kind of you know what they just
that um i i feel
bad that sometimes i feel this way
but
i mean these girls they're my whole
world but sometimes it's
it feels like i am grieving
what i expected motherhood to look like
um you know with everything going on
with cadence that
i feel like i'm constantly kind of on
edge and you know worried and
keeping an extra extra close eye on her
almost like i'm waiting for the other
shoe to drop
and i think that i am just struggling to
sometimes take a deep breath
and try to enjoy the moment a little bit
more
so can you do me a huge favor
yes will you
redo that whole thing i'm gonna re-ask
you the question
okay and you
apologized and minimized before you even
said what's going on in your heart and
head
and i want you to rephrase it and i want
you to tell me exactly
no no
i'm afraid i'm gonna get found out or
i'm afraid someone i'm not allowed to
say these things i'm a mom and i'm
supposed to feel i want you to tell me
what's actually going on in your heart
and head is that cool that's cool okay
so we'll hit rewind and for those of you
who don't know where rewind is because
you're young it's this thing we used to
do with tapes and it was incredible so
we'll rewind and then
so hey so what's going on michelle let's
go tell me what's going on why'd you
call
hey uh
i'm going because
i am struggling with the fact that
motherhood
is turning out differently than what i
always imagined okay let's rewind and do
it again hey michelle what's going on
be more honest
okay uh hey dr d i'm doing great
no
rewind again i'll i'll help you
hey dr d i'm so pissed off that my
two-year-old has all these physical and
um disability challenges
i am super pissed that all my friends
kids seem to be all perfect and on
instagram everything's going great i'm
so pissed that i just can't hug my
nine-year-old without worrying that
my two-and-a-half-year-old's gonna fall
down or my three-year-old's gonna have
some issue
i'm so pissed that we had to move again
and i love that we're in the military
but god almighty can we just get some
community is that closer to you
yeah that's closer too
and i hate that for you
i hate that somebody told you you're not
allowed to feel your feelings right now
i hate that somebody told you that
um
oh by the way your daughter's gonna
screw up everything so don't worry you
know all that stuff you're carrying so
tell me where you're where you're really
truly at i also did a really annoying
thing which i want to call out that
i'm some
man that you've never met telling you
what your feelings are out loud i just
did that and that was pretty lame of me
um
you give me your own words what are you
experiencing
um
so in my own words i think it's
i mean you kind of hit it right on the
head um you know i'm seeing
my friends do all these different things
with their children and it's things that
i would love to do with cadence but
we're not able to or
you know we attempt to and the outcome
isn't
exactly what
you know that exactly what i wanted it
to be or what i thought it would be like
you know even as as little as
going and taking her to
do something that i think she would have
fun doing and
um
she ends up not enjoying it or it's just
a bad day and
it's just
not not what i i thought that it would
be are any of these things rolling off
that
you're a bad mom
like this isn't this is your fault
um a little bit i've been working
through that for a long time um
i feel like that's it's kind of been
in my head since cadence started missing
her milestones you know and she was just
a baby
so some of the with some of the the
parents i've worked with over the years
i've seen it over and over where
their kid is born with a genetic issue
or with a learning disability or some
sort of challenge
and then
mom and or dad often mom sometimes dad
own this as though this is our fault
something about us created this child
with these challenges
and then it becomes super your job to
make sure that they are catching up
whatever that means that they are having
super tons of fun whatever that means
and with kids with special needs they
don't always have fun in traditional
ways they don't communicate in
traditional ways they do things
differently the circus may scare the
crap out of them or they may be too
short to ride the roller coaster for a
long time or whatever the thing is
and that just compounds this
ceaseless never-ending guilt so i'm am i
on the right track there
you are okay and then you get pissed
at your kid
they're not having fun or you get mad at
your friend and then you feel guilty
about getting mad or you feel guilty
about
it's just this never-ending cycle of
guilt is that is that fair yes
it is it's very fair ugh
so
have you said out loud i hate this
i have not okay i need you to to know
it's okay to say that
in fact you have to
if you don't acknowledge how you truly
feel
there will be a widening gap between the
problems your body is trying to solve
for you
and this facade this fake universe
you're trying to create where it's
different but it's okay you know what i
mean
and it's not okay
it's not
it's not how we drew it up
right
and then we got to deal with the and
this is what is this is the reality
how's your husband doing with this
uh he's
he's doing
okay you know we've had these
discussions where
well before we got the diagnosis for
cadence it was a lot of you know what
what are you most worried about and a
lot of times it always came back to
you know what if it is progressive or
degenerative and i prayed and prayed and
prayed and luckily this condition is not
that so
i i'm so grateful for that and so i
think that's part of where some of the
gulp comes from too because
it could be worse so i try to minimize
what it truly is
uh very good and you know comparing
grief
just takes your soul from me
yeah yeah could never compare grief like
oh my mom passed away but she was 70 so
i had more time than my friend's mom
man your mom passed away right so it's
just sitting in that hard stuff
um have you all had a
i'll just say this this is this isn't
related to your question but i think
it's important to have those type of
conversations with some regularity
good for you guys y'all are way ahead of
the curve for having this conversation
before she was born but i think it's
good to have check-in conversations
every couple of months just how's our
experience how are you right
you know what i mean to check back in
because this whole all these milestones
are going to be different now
um so what's your question question i
feel like i'm talking too much what's
your question question
you're not talking too much
um i think
my question question is how do i
do i just live more in the moment
without having to feel so heavy all of
the time
ah that's such a good question
so i want you to think of that weight
you feel that inability to breathe
as your body trying to experience the
reality of what you're living in
versus what your head is trying to
convince yourself is actually going on
what i mean by that is your body knows
that your daughter's hurting
your body knows
that
it wants to be over here with your
special needs daughter and with your
nine month old
your body knows oh by the way i'm
supposed to fill in the blank around the
house and whatever and at work and with
my husband all that stuff
and your head's trying to say yeah but
it could be worse so we're all okay
everybody just smile let's get in the
mini van let's go you know what i mean
there's a gap yeah and so think of that
weight
that i love to use that word that
heaviness
as it's gonna sound so cheesy please
don't roll your eyes
as unfelt feelings that you gotta
acknowledge are there
and instead of
trying to pretend they're not real i
want you to enter into an intentional
space of i'm going to feel sad for the
next hour
i'm going to be intentional about it
and for me i write that stuff down and
it doesn't work for everybody some
people need to say it out loud and tell
a friend um you've heard me say a
million times grief demands a witness
and so having somebody you can say
i hate all of this
and
i love love love being a mom and i love
my babies and i love that i was chosen
to be the person to navigate all of this
nobody else could do this and love these
kids like i can
and i hate that i got this assignment
you know what i mean
yeah so it's both and and if you try to
blow past one or the other then your
body's gonna wear it
and it doesn't mean it's all going to be
roses but you will go through life
lighter you'll hold it looser and so
we're all going to the circus today and
you get to the circus and cadence has
just an absolute barn burner meltdown or
she has a seizure six six minutes in and
you gotta leave
um you'll hold that loosely instead of
i didn't worry it will be a loosely held
well we gave it a good shot and now
we're gonna go
take care of this this and this and this
and we're gonna be able to turn the
corner there right
what does
feel in that look like for you
um
i feel like
feeling that probably is just
taking some time to really just sit
there and i probably just need to cry
out for a little bit because i try not
to do that
yeah please don't please don't hold that
in
um a lot of times the grief swirls
around inside of us
and getting it out
letting it be heard whether you write it
down tell somebody that's important i
can sit and stew for a long time and
like have a quote unquote quiet time
whatever that means and i come away more
fried than
before i went in
if i don't sit down and write stuff out
and actually put it down on paper
um
hang on a second kelly would you be able
to weigh in here
yeah sure um the main thing that i would
say hold up a second michelle
kelly tell michelle your situation so
michelle we have um two special needs
kids one far more than the other um our
daughter has spina bifida she has
she's 18 but she's only about five
developmentally and there's also some
mental illness
so
quite a bit going on there the one thing
that i would say because you talked
about how there's certain things
that your your daughter can't do certain
things you know those kind of places we
wanted to take the family and things
that we wanted to do
there's a fine line between
we do these things as a family together
because this is what everyone can do
but
also knowing that
it's okay for you to get her a sitter
sometimes and take your other kids to do
those things
okay does that make sense
yeah okay
we do that often like we took our
daughter to disney
and it was all it was awful it did not
go well day one she looked at me like
five minutes in and said i want to go
home it's like great we have seven days
left awesome
and we
can't go home so we know that we're
probably going to go next year she won't
go she hated it it was awful for
everyone nobody had a good time so
she'll probably go to my in-laws where
she has their undivided attention for
you know six seven days and that's her
idea of heaven
yeah
and you know we want to take our son to
the beach well the wheelchair doesn't go
really well over the beach over the sand
so
she has camps that she goes to as well
that's something we can talk about off
arabic the camps are great in the summer
and then when we use that time to take
our son somewhere else so you can still
do those things with your other children
and and that's okay too because they
need to have those quote unquote normal
experiences as well
okay that makes a lot of sense thank you
so much for sharing that with me of
course and kelly can you
because i all of mine is theoretical i
haven't sat in the seat
um what wisdom would you give to
michelle about those days when you're
just pissed off
that
um you've got hurting kids or that you
just want to be able to go on a date and
not have to deal with fill in the blank
yeah
there are days you're going to be pissed
i mean there's we we've had our daughter
we adopted our daughter 13 years ago
and i've still pissed half the time
because it's not what we thought was
going to happen it's not what we thought
was going to be
and my husband and i know that it's okay
for me to
you know gripe to him and him to gripe
to me
because that's our safe space to do that
and i've also got a group of friends i
can do that with and they know that
because i know that if anybody outside
heard me i would sound like a horrible
human being for some of the things that
i gripe about
and but that's okay if you have that
safe place that you can do that with
your spouse and then i really recommend
a group of girlfriends too that will let
you do that without thinking wow she's
awful because they just know you're in a
crap situation and there's just no way
around it it sucks
but you have to have those and you have
to have those outlets to talk about it
and then you have to laugh at really
really inappropriate things
you know because you're just like you
have to because if not you'll just cry
all the time that's why kelly's perfect
this particular show
yeah because you just have to laugh and
you're like
i just
our life is stupid but you know what
it's ours and there's some great times
in it and there's some really really
hard times but you have to find great
sitters that you know can handle your
child so you can go get out there's
churches in our area that do what they
call respite nights
um
our church does one once a month where
our kids get to go and we get to have a
date night for free
so there are things like that you can
find to offer those little oasises kind
of in the desert that you're that you're
in
if you you have to look for them but
don't
isolate yourself because then you'll
just
be under your bed in the fetal position
yes which is where i usually am after
this show after kelly's talking in my
ear too
hey um thanks so much kelly hey michelle
will you do me a huge favor two things
number one
be honest with yourself
okay okay don't hide from you
and that's such a temptation you are
allowed to have your feelings
and it's both hand
and obviously you got to get up and make
sure everybody's fed make sure
everybody's loved and go figure out what
the day is going to look like it's not
one or the other and we live in a
culture that says you do one of the
other you just led by your feelings and
if you feel sad you just yolo and sit in
bed and watch netflix
and then the other side of it is
a good mom whatever that means looks
like this whatever that means and you
are always feeling less than so you
want you to take permission to feel how
you feel
um and love how you love
and you got to get up and do the right
thing the second thing is is kelly
mentioned it please get a gang and i
know that's so hard in a military family
where you're moving and moving and
moving and moving um but continue to
reach out to continue to reach out and
make sure you got a crew around you is
that cool okay that's cool i can do that
and call us back now you're now you're
like in the fam so call us back and
we'll just keep going on especially
because in like a couple of years
there's gonna be some
knucklehead little kid thinking
constance is so your daughter's so
beautiful and
we'll tell you how to
get in a fight with a six-year-old right
my husband already taught her how to
shake her head no when he said he'll
tell her he'll say what do you say when
all the boys say they want kisses and
she'll shake her head and say no no no
excellent excellent
excellent i love it love it
well michelle you're a saint thank you
so much for calling in and thanks for
being honest
[Music]
you got a hard road to hoe and a blessed
road to hoe and it's the same it's both
and and it's a mess and it's
chaos and it's joy
and um thanks for calling and trusting
with us trusting with us trusting us
even uh even me hey thank you so much
we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to alyssa
in fargo north dakota
that was my far going indian accent and
it was dreadful i apologize alyssa
i've heard
yes
yes
um i just love finding out i'm not the
worst of things i don't have to be great
as long as you know somebody in your
mind that's worse that makes me happy so
what's up melissa how can i help
um okay so basically
my husband and i have been married for
like 10 11 days
and
hold on hold on 10 or 11 days
yeah
wow okay cool do we do we already have
problems
not with him he's perfect well i mean
he's fine but gross no he's not yuck
you've only been married ten days that's
so good okay all right he's perfect i
love him good for you all right so
what's the deal so
i'm already like stressing out about you
know like
holidays two families last year we did
like both sides it was awful for us
um
they still didn't weren't pleased with
how everything was set up
but more yeah
so why are you what you're you're day 10
why are you stressing about this
so my husband says i'm a catastrophizer
hold on he says this are you
um
i tend to overthink
a lot
that's such an undersell so you're a
catastrophizer
what's your favorite what's your
favorite catastrophe you've thought of
over the last 18 months
let's just get into this i love
catastrophizers oh god i don't know um
he believed me we paid all this money
for a wedding it wouldn't happen
so when when he actually showed up and
put the ring on did you exhale like all
right sweet dodge dodge that one
um
well no because then there was like so
many other things that could go wrong
this way
okay so
let's just get to the actual reason you
called
you are 10 days into your new marriage
and you've described him as perfect and
wonderful and so lovely
so you won right he's a good guy you
married well
right yes
and it's not even
you know it's not even a winter yet
there's already a hundred inches of snow
on the ground in fargo i'm assuming
yeah basically all right basically 101.
so y'all are sitting in the deep snow
together in love 10 days in and you look
over and you see him and snowflakes are
gathering on his
eyelashes
and
yeah you've got one hand on his shoulder
just rubbing his back it's so good and
then you think uh
just a few short months
disaster we've got thanksgiving and
christmas and what's gonna happen and
then your body races to
fight that problem or to flee that
problem
oh you're so great okay so
what did you screw up last year
um well we went to both sides
that was ridiculous what else did you do
come on alyssa i know
what else happened um we only
well basically
his mom wasn't pleased that we could
only stay there for like five hours by
the time ridiculous
what kind of daughter-in-law are you
going to be alyssa what else happened
um well actually that was mostly it my
mom seems to understand it a little bit
more which is surprising
so
you're my favorite person i've talked to
in a long time so oh thank you i want to
distill this catastrophe down
so ah
you stayed for five hours and his mom
said i wish you'd stayed longer
what else did she do did she like let
the air out of your tires did as you
were pulling away did she lean into your
ear and say you've ruined my life and i
hate the fact that you're in my family
did she say that
no his mom is super sweet we get along
real great
what did she do that was a disaster
oh his mom is
non-confrontational at all um are you
usually yes i am
um
she's super easy going so when she like
freaked out at him over the phone and
this is all for pam
that we would only be able to stay for
so long
it was kind of like okay is this what
we're going to be dealing with every
year when we decide to just go to my
family
i mean
that type of thing yeah and i think part
of my stress comes from like how my
husband
doesn't like
handle letting people down very well and
i'm kind of just like well it is what it
is
yes
um and so you have a an avoider and a
catastrophizer all in the same
house
and
when an avoider is married to a
catastrophizer but the catastrophizer
always feels is that we are about to
drive off a cliff
and the avoider is like it's cool
there'll be a road there'll just be a
road
and the catastrophizer is like there's
no road there's no road there's no road
and then usually there is a road or
there's not but there's not even a fall
and everyone just it's a lot of spinning
up in chaos for nothing
is that fair
yeah that sounds pretty accurate have
you ever told him
i don't like that you won't address this
head-on with your mom because you almost
have been dating for a while this can't
be a surprise
right um
i don't know if i've ever said it very
clearly i think i just get annoyed with
him yeah there you go because yeah you
want him to
uh read your mind and let say to your
his mom exactly what you would say to
her if it was your mom but he won't and
then you just stay quiet and you know
where that all leads right
right to resentment
and then you just get super angry all
the time
and then he gets angry that you're angry
and you all don't know why each other
wasn't just doing what and then we end
up in
the catastrophe you were so scared of is
a self-fulfilling prophecy
so you ready for my little uh
simple foolproof plan here
sure
do you know what it's going to be
is it going to be the emails
like emailing this is what we're doing
or oh you can that's what i would do
that's what i do that's what i i was
gonna say i do do but i don't wanna say
that that's what we do in my house but
um
do you not wanna do the email are you
scared of it i just don't think it'll go
over well it probably won't because
here's why your husband hasn't had this
conversation yet
so you all aren't at email land yet
what you need to do is sit down your
husband and say
we're going to head this off at the pass
i'm not going to
be nervous or
i'm not going to want to avoid
holidays for the rest of our life
thanksgiving christmas halloween those
things are too precious they're too
they're they're too important to
communities and neighborhoods into
family units we're not going to avoid
that and so this year already we're
going to put a stake in the ground and
say this is what we're going to do
so you all have that conversation have
you had that conversation that this year
we're going to go we're going to go to
thanksgiving this year and christmas on
that year and we're going to alternate
every year whatever it's going to be
have you all had that conversation yet
yeah we kind of have i've told him what
i think would be best he kind of is just
like i don't want to talk about the
holidays
yeah so we need to talk about the
holidays
yeah and if he doesn't want to talk
about the holidays you need to be very
clear with him about letting him know
this is stressing you out
the lack of clarity on what we're doing
more importantly
i'm i'm your new wife and whether i want
to or not whether it's wise or not i
don't want your mom
to
not like me right now
as lame as that sounds i don't want that
so
i want to get some clarity on the
holiday season before we enter enter
into it i want to get clarity on our
calendar i want to get clarity about
who's buying what gifts for who and how
let's just get all that
down and i think being real clear you
say he doesn't want to talk about it but
you also said you're not very clear with
him i think letting him know here's
going to be these are going to be the
important uh big rocks for me
and i want these to be important big
rocks for us and i want to dream about
what is thanksgiving going to look like
and christmas going to look like and
then let's be honest with all of our
family members reverse engineering that
and at some point yes you'll probably
get to the email world or
he can just have a clear conversation
with his mom and my hope is he will not
be a coward about that but will tell his
mom hey mom here's what we're doing for
the holidays not i hope it's okay and
here's what we were thinking about
here's what we are doing me and my
new wife my little new family this is
what we're gonna do and mom's going to
bang her head up against that boundary
and then you'll have to hold firm and
then mom will know oh cool if i want to
be in my kid's life because they're
adults just like i raise them
then i'm going to be a part of their
holidays not the other way around
is that fair
yeah and by the way expect her to be
have her be sad because she has a
picture of what
her married son's life is gonna look
like and it's probably gonna involve a
lot of her
and it's gonna be hard for her to
realize that's not how that works
and so she'll kick and scream and act
like a child you can't control that
you can just know ah she loves her son
she loves me and she had a picture of
how she's gonna go and we made it
different so ta-da
and yeah you know i've said this a lot
the earlier you can work through life
where you love your mother-in-law you
respect her but she doesn't get a vote
in your decisions the easier and more
more um the better your relationship
will be with her and the lighter you'll
walk through life
she doesn't get a vote yeah
right well it's 10 times easier for me
to get along with her than my mother so
your mom
a whole other call you struggle with
your mom too
i mean that's like a whole other call
it's typical mother-daughter stuff ah
so
it's hard for parents to let their kids
go be married
and especially i've seen this with
mother-daughter relationships she
doesn't want you to experience some of
the things she experienced as a
young
wife
and
that's your life
and so those boundaries are so so
important you sound like you knew the
answer and you don't want to do it what
are you hesitant about
well
maybe part of it is like i need
to know if we're just being like if i'm
just being a baby because we don't want
to go to both sides
why would you hear that cause like it's
your holiday we're young we don't have
kids it's your holiday you can
you can do whatever you want
you just gotta be honest about it
if you are unclear and kind of wavering
other people will backfill that with
their stories and so if you wait till
november 15th to say
oh we're still kind of deciding what
then your mother-in-law or your mom is
going to create thanksgiving pictures
with y'all in them
so if you're not going to go be clear
way up front
be clear way up front
if you don't want to go just say
we are newlyweds and we're going to do
our own thing this year
it's harder when you have kids because
then you think well i don't want to keep
my grandkids from their grandparents
want them to have a relationship if
you're going to skip out on stuff now is
the time to do it
we're going to go to
we're in fargo north dakota we're going
to florida that's what we want to do for
christmas we're just going to go buy
ourselves to the beach
and um we will send cards
and we get to do that because it's our
life and we're grown-ups
and
getting to the place where you're again
respectful treat people dignity but
you're not apologetic for what you want
to do
your life
you and your husband's life y'all
co-created together but there is a
desperate need for clarity in your home
desperate need for you to be honest with
him about how you feel let him be honest
with you about how he feels and then
y'all just co-create this thing together
and then whether that's a phone call
clear phone call
or emails to family members whatever
that looks like man let that go and then
go have a fun thanksgiving look forward
to your holidays don't dread them don't
dread them
have the hard conversations and go get
them thank you for the call listen you
rule talk to you soon
i actually i want to know how it all
goes so let's know how thanksgiving goes
call me back because that would be a fun
show that's james we're going to do that
show
the um
holidays got off the rails show we need
to put the bookmark that one because
that'll just be fun or we had the
boundaries conversation and it was a
disaster that'll be fun uh show too all
right we'll be right back on the doctor
john lynch oh wait what if we do like a
three-way call where we get the couple
and the in-laws oh my god and the other
in-laws on the phone and just hash it
all out in the air we got people in the
lobby thumbs up in that yes we're gonna
do a hash out live on the air and i'll
be referee and kelly will just come in
and be like you all need to shut your
mouth this would be so fun i'm in 100 i
mean if you want your family to have
this conversation live on the air with
me as a referee and kelly and james as
referee spectators and with pom-poms and
throwing stuff at people
shoot kelly an email at
johnodelling.com
ask is that what it is
yeah that'd be so good i can't wait all
right we'll be right back on the doctor
john dolan show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back and kelly sent me
this email
and it's a unique take on a question
that we get all the time about grief and
so i wanted to go through this email
today
emails from greg he said how can i
comfort a friend that is grieving
a close friend lost a relative to
suicide they died by suicide and i don't
know what to do
and i feel like i'm walking on eggshells
the eggshells
um egg shales eggshells
what are some do's and don'ts great
question greg great question
um so whether somebody is passed away by
suicide or whether somebody is just had
a hard
stuff going on whether it's big stuff
little stuff
i mean greg nailed it how often do we
walk through life walking on eggshells i
know so and so's wife just moved out on
them i know so and so just got fired i
know
someone says mom's in the hospital cove
whatever
and we just walk around on eggshells
that's so frustrating and here's why
it's super frustrating number one we
want to help we want to be supportive we
want to love people in our lives and we
don't know how to do it and we feel like
there's a
there's a certain train track we need to
be on and we can't find it we don't know
what it is and
when people are hurting they need people
who will love them
and they know that everybody's walking
on eggshells around them
and they know that they're the weird one
now whose husband passed away in a car
wreck whose wife is super super sick
they know
and they also don't have the energy or
the time of the desire to teach
everybody in that moment and so they end
up spending more and more time alone and
it gets to become this recurring
cycle of avoidance and loneliness and
please reach out and i want to reach out
but i don't know how so great great
question greg
here's a couple of
things that have served me well
i don't do this perfectly all the time
but this is
this is the way i've tried to get
through it
um and the way i teach people to get
through it number one don't ignore it
one of the
things we think
like we have somebody who passed away
from suicide died by suicide somebody is
mom is sick
we think that if we bring it up that we
are going to suddenly remind somebody of
this hurt
if we bring it up we're gonna suddenly
they're gonna be like oh i wasn't even
thinking about that today and now you
reminded me that's not how it works if
my mom's in the hospital i know she's in
the hospital
if someone i love has just passed away i
know they've passed away so
number one is don't ignore it don't
avoid it
lean into that discomfort and most of
the time the discomfort is on you
i don't know how to ask if your mom with
cancer is doing okay i don't know how to
ask if you're doing okay after your
husband just moved out on you
you say directly
i know your mom is sick and she's not
doing well how are you
i'm still heartbroken that you lost your
wife in a car wreck how are you doing
how are we doing right now
that's a question i ask a lot i don't
want people to feel alone how are we
doing you're on my team and how are we
doing
and it's just leaning into that
conversation
um not avoiding it not beating around
the bush but going directly into it you
are not going to remind somebody that
they are grieving or hurting
you're not in fact the more you can lean
and say you're not by yourself
it's it will send messages to their
brain that says i've got a tribe i got a
gang i'm i've got people with me they
might burst into tears they probably
won't they probably will say things are
really hard right now or they'll lie to
you and say things are fine
so number one don't ignore it number two
ask directly how are you doing
how are you doing
and the next question beneath that how
are you doing is
what can i do to love you right now
now if you are 55 years old and you're
talking to some grizzled old buddy of
yours you may not say
hey man how can i love you better right
now
but you can say are you eating
are you sleeping i'm bringing dinner
what night this week works for you
because if you say hey do you need
anything they're going to say no
say i'm bringing food this week
i'm getting you doordash this week i'm
going to
i'm sending an amazon delivery to your
house period
you can speak into what's going to be in
there otherwise i'm going to get bananas
and send something
but it is leaning into
how can i demonstrate that i care about
you and that you matter to me
often people are gonna say
nothing i'm fine i'm good all that
beneath that
number four is
ask letting them speak into it
what i mean by that is don't just show
up to somebody's house over and over and
over again
but do ask
can i come by
let them say no thank you not today and
you don't get your feelings hurt this
isn't about you this is about them
so reaching out saying hey can i come by
today are you up for a phone call today
i'll shoot a text message up for a phone
call today can we chit chat
um not today i'm not feeling like i can
talk on the phone today um or sure i'd
love to
and you can talk about funny things or
silly things and going back to number
one you can be really direct
i'm so sorry that you lost so and so i'm
still with you how are you how are we
doing are you eating are you
sleeping are you going for walks
um and the last thing that i always
think this is important is to send
handwritten letters
um
that they can
people are struggling and they're in
grief their heads are all over the place
their hearts and their minds and their
bodies are responding all over the place
and there's something about a
handwritten letter they can go back to
and go back to i've heard from parent
after parent after parent after parent
whose kid has passed away that letters
are gold
they are worth their weight in gold
because they can hold them and go back
to him and go back to him and go back to
him it's just a currency of love
and so write letters hand written
letters notes draw funny pictures
um i've sent banan like crazy things in
envelopes just to be just i want someone
to open an envelope and then be like
what dolony doing i just want to add a
moment of levity or a moment of love a
moment of i'm thinking about you but you
can reach out all of this comes back to
this one thing
don't shy away from it lean into it
followed by let somebody else tell you
how you can best love them one of the
worst things we can do is to say
somebody's hurting i know what they need
and then we try to do something that is
counterproductive it's not going to help
them so hope that helps great question
greg great question um we'll link to
some stuff in the show notes if we've
got it and um
thanks for trying to love people in your
community greg that's awesome
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're gonna go back to uh
alyssa from fargo
for who her and her
uh ten-day-old marriage
she loves that husband loves him
but it's the mother-in-law and her
mother all of it
i'm gonna remind you alyssa of what the
great bill withers the great grover
washington junior
their joint song
went a little bit like this
it's called just the two of us
i see the crystal raindrops fall and the
beauty of it all is when the sun comes
shining through
to make those rainbows in my mind when i
think of you sometime i want to spend
some time with you
just the two of us
we can make it if we try just the two of
us just the two of us just the two of us
building castles in the sky just the two
of us who alyssa
i was gonna say you and i but it's not
you and i it's
you and husband i just made this weird
as always on the dr john delaney show
you